le patron affiche les gains de ses
clients normals mais ce qu'il préfère
lui ce sont les tickets perdants il en a
tapissé tous les murs du café un buzz le
de 10 000 tickets qui lui permet
aujourd'hui de décrocher le gros lot
l'entrée dans le livre des records la
tapisserie était pas très jolie mange
pas trop de sous et puis on cherche
souvent des idées très loin on va
chercher toujours des idées très loin
alors qu'elles étaient l'idée de
retapisser le café tu es en face de moi
ça plaît ça fait rire et ce n'est pas
fini tenez vous bien sur les murs du bar
plusieurs jeux sont représentés bingo
millionnaire blackjack mais pas de
morpion oublie erreur pas du tout ce
sera même dans un prochain avenir la
cerise sur le gâteau et je ferai les
toilettes avec les morpions
quand les gens connaissent mon nom alors
là c'est encore pire bon enfin
non gardez les morpions pour les
toilettes quand on s'appelle bidet il
fallait quand même le faire